straight my day junkie block my night
all day so Anaheim you there I'm down a
suicide it's good one to I hope nobody
[ __ ] up for the fight and we always
kind of brought last weekend you should
check out that show that her business
her business this past weekend Daniel
Cormier hit John Jones in the face with
a water bottle to present Andy and John
try to Chuck one at him and they almost
brawled and keep up got water bottles at
the press conferences well they now they
dream the monster energy cans so when
you see those Monster energy drinks
they're sitting there under the dance
those are fake the real monster energy
drinks but they have to drink them all
or empty them out before they get up
there right I'm so exciting oh it's okay
and just the this John Jones that is so
interesting that that press conference
where John Jones is talking all positive
like now I want to show that you can get
back on your feet and you know this and
then karma is awaited on a second these
vaccines you told me and the biggest
[ __ ] I ever saw
yeah and then I yeah that was
fascinating the way that played out well
John is starting to come clean now
trying to be more himself this past
weekend they had a press conference and
he said that I can doing cocaine all
weekend long before he beat him
well Daniel Cormier said Daniel was
talking on [ __ ] what is this fight even
going to happen who knows if John gets
caught doing cocaine or sandblasting a
prostitute
what is sandblasting up I don't know is
rhetoric so hilarious term Daniels funny
man
I did commentary with in this bounce
right so anything funny [ __ ] dude man
I find that on your IG story yeah yeah
and so anyway when John said that I beat
you after I did cocaine for a weekend
everybody's like oh [ __ ] like I like
that John is being himself that's that's
that's what I'll serve him better then
all this fake right face like I'm just a
good guy and lifting yeah well he
doesn't want to be uplifting too but
when it comes to like actual fighting
he's a [ __ ] straight-up killer John
Jones is a killer that's I mean you
don't get to be the youngest every UFC
champion if you're not a killer he got
he showed up he fought Mauricio Shogun
who
in his UFC title fight who is like a
legend in Brazil his opening move was a
flying knee he threw a flying knee on
Mauricio Shogun who oh that is just
crazy I mean you have to be such a
gangster to even think about doing that
to a guy like she not still feeling him
out he just leaped in it through a
[ __ ] flying me at Shogun's face and
caught him and beat his ass and stopped
him when he was like 22 won the World
title this is bananas you know John was
something special and still is but it's
gonna you know it's gonna be a raw a
long tough fight with him and Cormier at
this time I think it's gonna be flying
away gonna be there I can't wait yeah I
just hope the car doesn't fall apart you
know cards fall apart so hard to get
through a can
[Applause]
[Music]